INSTRUCTOR: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to the content
video on graphs
implementation in Python.
All right, so the
previous videos,
we've talked about the
graph data structure
and how to implement it and
how to traverse a graph.
But this video is where
the rubber meets the road
and how you actually
do it in Python.
So we are going to use the
Python library called Networkx.
Networkx has some really
easy-to-implement,
very well-written
professional library.
That's easy to use.
It's great, Networkx.
So there are a couple--
if you look in the--
if you look in the file
here, find_paths.py,
you can see I've actually
included the commands to install
Networkx and Matplotlib so
that you can actually print out
graphs and look at
what the graphs--
look at all the nodes and
look at all the edges and see
what's in the graph.
So those commands
are right there.
So what I'm going to do right
now is just go through this code
really quickly, point out
how the data is loaded,
how the nodes and
edges are created,
how to traverse the
graph, and how to use
the data to make decisions.
OK, so once you've got
your libraries installed,
this next part right here,
this matplotlib.use 'Agg',
that basically
puts the matplotlib
and lets you use
matplotlib in server mode
because there's no
desktop environment here.
We're running this
on an AWS server.
So all of the visuals that
I generate with matplotlib,
I'm going to save them
as files, as PNG files.
So I can look at the graph and
look at the visuals that way.
All right, then I'm going to
import my networkx library,
and then I'm going
to get my data.
So here I've got just a simple--
a simple edges.txt here.
And if you recall
back from our graph
here when we talked about
Dijkstra's, this is the graph
that we're implementing.
So all of this node
and edge information
I put into this file edges.txt.
So every edge v0,v1,2; v0,v3,1;
v1,v3,3; all of those--
it's node, node, edge,
so v0,v1,2; v0,v3,1--
all of that information
is stored here.
So this is-- this is our
graph information right here.
OK, now back in
python, I'm going
to load that file, edges.txt,
right here with this edges file.
I should also point
out this is a really
nice, easy-to-use
library, os.path.dirname.
This will basically get you
whatever file I'm running here.
It'll give me the
directory that I'm
in right now that the file
that I'm running is in.
So since I've got edges.txt
in the same folder
as find_paths.py, it'll
go and grab those edges.
And then I'm going
to put them, and I'm
going to create my graph.
OK, so check out line
41, g = nx.DiGraph.
This is going to create
our graph object.
So it starts out
as an empty graph,
and then we fill it up with
all our nodes and edges.
So line 48 here--
I created a list-- it's empty
right now, but of all the edges.
So all this edge
information and edges.txt--
it's going to go in there.
And then I'm going to
add it into my graph.
So how do I do that?
I go through all of
the lines in the file.
I split on the comma to get
my node 1, node 2, and weight.
Again, if you go over
to edges right here,
so that would be my node 1,
node 2, and weight right here,
v0,v1,2.
I iterate through
all of those edges,
and then I append them here.
Notice how I don't just--
they're all tuples, so I need
a way to identify the actual--
the edge I need.
So it's by a tuple.
So I have node 1, node
2 weight, all comma
separated in this tuple.
And I add on that edge.
I do it over and
over and over again.
And here's the function
where all the magic happens.
g.add_weighted_edges_from.
So that right there--
from tells you
it's a directed graph
from node 1 to node 2.
I give it all of my
edges, and that's it.
Line 56 right there creates
the entire graph for me.
I should also point
out, if you ever--
another really
easy-to-use function
that's really useful in
networkx is add a single edge.
If you either want to add an
edge later or add all the edges
one at a time as you get
new data, things like that,
add edge.
Add just one more
edge to the graph,
as opposed to line 56
when it adds everything.
OK, then I can print my notes
to see if they look like.
And this code is really useful.
This is matplotlib right
here, line 67 through 72,
where I save my visual.
So I can look at
my graph and see--
make sure that the data
is everything's correct.
In fact, before I traverse it,
I'm going to run it that far.
And then we can take a look
at the graph that got created.
OK, so here is my
new graph_visual.png.
And let's take a look.
So here's my nodes.
Here's all the
edges, and you can
see it included the edge
weights on top of the edges.
So that's nice and easy to see.
Let's compare it to the one that
I had in mind before right here.
You can see it doesn't-- it
doesn't really have a set way
of orienting anything.
It just kind of--
it spaces things out evenly
to make a a good visual,
essentially.
So it doesn't really, that
I've seen, have a method to--
maybe it does if
you go one by one
and you fix the position
of all the nodes.
Then you could get the exact
look you're looking for.
Like, if you wanted to
recreate a physical map,
something like that.
But anyway, this is still
a really good visual
to make sure that the
graph structure, all
of the nodes and the
edges are intact.
So that's nice.
OK, so then how--
we've got our graph.
We've built it.
We can look at it to
make sure it's correct.
How do we use it?
How do we analyze the
data that's in the graph?
How do we traverse the graph
to look for things we want?
Here's how you do it.
So what I'm going
to do right now,
check out my for
loop on line 80 here.
I'm going to go through
every node parent here using
the permutations function.
So again, permutations--
permutations
is different than combinations.
As a quick reminder,
permutations
is like if you have 10
people and you say, OK, I
want to make a presidency
of three, well,
the order matters
in a presidency.
You've got a president, a
vice president number 1,
vice president number 2.
So if order matters,
you use permutations.
That's the way to remember that,
PP, Permutation Presidency.
Combination is similar,
but order does not matter.
So that's like a committee.
If you have 10 people and you
need to take those 10 people
and then, out of them, create
a committee of three people,
order doesn't matter.
You would use combinations.
Well, here what I'm
going to go through
is I'm going to look for
all the paths from one node
to another node.
And since it's a directed
graph, order does matter.
So I want to use
permutations where--
where position matters.
So I'm going to go through
here and get for n1, n2,
which is node 1, node 2.
All of those
combinations-- excuse me,
all of those
permutations-- let's
be exact here because I just
told you the difference.
I'm going to go through all the
permutations of those two nodes
in the graph and then prints
out here's the path from them.
All right, now here's
another magical function
I love of all the-- here's
the magical functions
you're going to learn today.
On line 56, add_weighted_edges,
which creates your graph
for you.
Very nice.
Here's another one that's even
more magic, all_simple_paths.
So this takes care of
traversing your graph for you.
It takes care of you.
You don't need to write
Dijkstra's by hand.
all_simple_paths will do
the traversal for you.
And basically, what it says
is, I want all of the paths
from one node to another.
So the shortest one
or the data you want,
I'm going to handle the
logic of looking through it
to get what I want out of there.
So I'm going to print
the path right there,
and then I'm going to
calculate the weight.
So this weight is a sum.
All of the weights
are going to add up
to be either the
shortest or the greatest,
and I'm going to
take a look at them.
I got a pathway of 0.
And then this little
loop right here-- this
goes through the path because
I need to know those edges.
Let me show you a visual again.
For example, to calculate
a path from v3 to v6--
or let's go to v5.
Let's go v3 to v2--
excuse me-- v3 to v4, from
v4 to v6, and v6 to v5,
what is that path?
Well, I need to add
up all of these edges.
OK, well, the edges are
going to be 2 plus 6 plus 1,
so that's going to be 9.
All right, it sums them up.
So back to the code, that's
exactly what it's doing.
I have a pathway
that starts at 0.
I loop through all
of the edges here.
And then I add them up, and then
I print out what the pathway is.
Let me point out one--
another little bit of syntax
you'll need for networkx.
When you want to specifically
go get an edge in the graph,
similar to how you in
an adjacency matrix,
it's two-dimensional, so it's
two indices, here it's similar.
But it's actually more
dictionary access style.
So I have g, my graph
object, and I give it
my path 1, which is going
to be a node, path i
plus one, the next
node in that path.
And then I say I
want the weight.
So this basically says, give
me the weight of this edge.
And then I go through the path
edge by edge, add them all up,
and that's my weight
of the entire path.
So let's give that a run.
And here they are.
Whoops, got on my--
so you can see a lot
of these right here.
These caught my eye right away.
There's a lot of paths that
don't exist from one node
to another, because
it's directed.
But a lot do, so let's take a
look at some of these that do.
In fact, let's take a look at--
here we go.
Let's go from the--
we'll do this one because
we can see them all.
All existing paths
from v0 to v2.
So here they are.
When it gives you
a path, it tells
you, here's all the nodes you
need to visit in that path.
And then we added them all
up, so there's the pathway,
pathway from v0,v1,2 is 7.
The pathway from v0v3v2
is three, and so on.
So now this does
not-- this does not--
whoop, reload that.
This does not include the
logic of all those paths.
Which one is the shortest?
I didn't add that here.
I'll let you do
something similar to that
in an assignment.
But that's how you would do it.
Right here, when you look
through all the paths, which
one--
and again, this is all
the paths that exist.
So this isn't Dijkstra's,
where we go from one node
to all other node.
What's the shortest?
This one is comprehensive.
Of all the permutations
of two nodes,
here's all the paths
to get from them.
And then if you
wanted to find out
which one was the
shortest or the greatest,
you would add that logic here.
OK, so I would recommend playing
with this, learning networkx.
The only way to
really learn network
is just try it out for yourself
and be hands-on with it
and really try and update
a graph or move data around
and make sure that you
understand how it all works.
And then you'll see
hopefully that networkx
is a very powerful, easy-to-use
graph library in Python.
All right, that concludes
this content video.
Thanks for watching.